philibert deux parties ce compte à sa
demande est tellement différent en
france 250 mille experts comptables et
pourtant ce métier est encore mal connue
casser les préjugés de cette profession
c'était tout l'enjeu de cette journée
destinée aux élèves de lycées et de bts
on entend toujours que valve comptable
c'est celui qui est pas beau qu'un pull
horrible et que sa calculette
mais on va voilà c'est une image a
changé cette image de personne réservée
et qui reste dans sa petite pièce fin ça
colle pas du tout à notre profession le
salaire est attractif en moyenne un
expert comptable en début de carrière
gagne 29 mille euros bruts par an un
commissaire aux comptes 35000 euros et
le secteur ne connaît pas la crise on
recrute beaucoup les besoins au niveau
national sont de l'ordre de dix mille
personnes par an et si on regarde
simplement au niveau du département
l'île de france
on peut considérer qu'il ya à peu près
un millier de jeunes qui rejoignent au
cabinet chaque année pour faire
connaître ses atouts une convention a
été signée avec un lycée de saint
germain en laye une première en ile de
france
les élèves vont pouvoir accéder à une
base de données professionnelles
soixante dix mille documents sont à leur
disposition il ya toute la jurisprudence
il peut utiliser ce terme là et qu'ils
vont découvrir autrement qu'en classe
quand ils vont être devant leur micro
ordinateurs qui vont pouvoir aller
chercher des documents qui sont
désormais mis à leur disposition et donc
ils vont pouvoir analyser cette
jurisprudence pour des questions qui
leur seront posées plus tard des
professions du chiffre au coeur de tous
les secteurs d'activité en france les
experts comptables et les commissaires
aux comptes aide chaque jour des
millions d'entreprises